let's go ahead and get started on this
very clicks ad title that drew a pretty
big crowd so you know is sparks still
relevant how many of you are hoping that
I'm gonna say no just a quick show of
hands alright so and yes why are the
rest of you here no it's fine I'm so so
about me I am currently a Solutions
Architect at anaconda that means that I
talk to most of our large customers
about problems that they're having in
this space how we how our enterprise
product can you know fit inside of their
infrastructure which is usually and are
prized how many here have done anything
in the enterprise involving like IT and
InfoSec and ticketing systems and yeah
ok so like some people here are fully
aware of that pain so you know we try
and help our customers navigate through
that minefield I'm also a part of the
Conda Forge core team before that I
worked an ad tech on a Hadoop platform
team that was you know a fun job but you
know it's ad tech so it's got its
downsides
before that I wrote scientific software
at Brookhaven before that I finished a
PhD in chemistry which is not at all
relevant for anything that I do today so
should you go to grad school the answer
is probably not so you know just keep
that in mind so my original talk plan
was to do a bake-off became task
sparking Rapids you know we have this
great downloads data set internally at
anaconda with billions of rows you know
basically compare desks park and Rapids
through kind of an end-to-end life cycle
of you know the kinds of problems that
we solve in the space that was a little
ambitious I didn't really really think
through how how much infrastructure I
was going to need to actually do a
proper bake-off so I'm a week ago after
I'd spent about a week and a half
fighting with parquet formats like I'm
gonna pin for this talk so we're not
we're not actually doing that this would
be great to do at some point it would
also be great as a blog post so
hopefully I'll have some time and space
to get that done I also came to the
realization that I'm not
move the needle with like an n plus one
talk on wide ask is functionally
equivalent to spark or like wide ask is
better or faster or why rapids as you
know orders of energy faster than both
of those because GPUs there are tons of
those out there already so you know feel
free to laugh at me about you know how
how ambitious that was so this talk
instead is not as far star relevant the
answer is yes so for those of you that
wanted me to you know dump on spark you
know you are welcome to leave I will not
be offended that is not what this talk
is so instead I'm gonna try and answer
the question of why our enterprise is
still choosing spark right I mean we're
all I mean many of us here no task or
Rapids or this ecosystem and really wish
that we could use it in our data they'd
jobs instead of spark but for you know
for reasons that hopefully will become
clear throughout this talk we're gonna
look at why that's not the case right
now so what is this about a brief
overview like you know what what do
businesses care about right these are
kind of my experiences from talking to
our anaconda enterprise customers you
know from talking with other people in
this space as well can we do a you know
hopefully a reasonably thorough job of
comparing these different ecosystems in
terms of different functionalities also
please feel free to come find me and I
will you know happily give you this this
talk deck so if you'd like if you're
taking pictures you know please feel
free but you know what we'll we'll
figure out a way to get you the talk
slides so comparing the ecosystems
across the number of metrics kind of
just an example like you know PowerPoint
version of what an implementation would
look like and then kind of some thoughts
at the end about how to actually drive
adoption into the enterprise's of these
technologies so first off who he knows
what spark is all right to ask and
Rapids okay so real quick cuz that
wasn't everybody in the room spark you
have distributed data frames on the JVM
on the CPU
- you have just super your data frames
on CPU at Python and Rapids is
distributed data frames and Python on
the GPU in very short there are many so
I know that tom is here on the desk team
I know that keith is here from Rapid so
if you want you know more info about
that then I would talk to them so what a
business is care about risk that's
that's kind of it that's like the big
thing that businesses are gonna be
focused on and everything else in this
talk really kind of centers around risk
and managing it and minimizing it and
understanding it and quantifying it in
two different ways that you can think
about risk you've got the notion of time
to value it right which is how fast am I
gonna start seeing this affect my bottom
line right how how much is this solution
gonna cost me to own right and you can
get answers to that with spark pretty
easily there's a there's an ocean of
people that you can go to for help here
I think there's one company that you can
go to with this for desk and that's Quan
site and they're brand new right like
there's not like if you look at this
ecosystem there's not as much available
in the desk space to service these kinds
of enterprise needs and certainly not in
Rapids because they're brand new I mean
you know they're doing a fantastic job
but they're still brand new right I mean
it's it's not like this is anything
unique to desk this is just what happens
with the brand new project SLA is in
support right who are you gonna call at
9:00 p.m. on a Tuesday when your
infrastructure falls over right you're
not gonna go post to the desk issue
tracker and say help well I mean you
probably are now because you can't go
pay anybody for this same thing with the
support right who are you gonna go when
you you know when task is almost the
right choice but you need a new feature
right you're not I don't know
welcome on site right but like there is
not a notion of these consultancies like
there is with spark and if you are in
that space please come talk to me
because it would be very useful for us
at anaconda to have a stable of these
kinds of companies and people that we
can you know talk to and work with to
help our clients do better sales pitch
done
all right so you know some examples of
like custom solutions that you would
want to implement right like you've got
desk and Rapids how do I bring that into
my existing entry right how do i hook it
into my existing off right so talking to
some people here they've they've told me
about their horrible homegrown all
systems right and these are not you know
small companies these are fortune 50
companies that have for whatever reason
decided to write their own off right
that's not gonna plug in easily so you
know you would need to pay somebody for
help with that you know connecting to a
database connection to your specific
type of networks file storage you know
how do you how do I push a desk job into
production with my enterprise scheduler
like these are things that businesses
care about you know and they will
happily pay people to to build out
custom pipelines for data engineering or
the machine learning finally training
right who are you gonna pay to get these
people up to speed right so you know
those of us that are in this room
already on that path of you know
becoming experts on tasks and Rapids but
there are a lot of people in the
enterprise that are not in this room
right now and you know maybe each of you
will go back and train the people around
you but realistically to make a dent in
the SPARC adoption inside of the
enterprise you need people that can go
and train so just in summary those five
things you will see this slide again I'm
not going to read a slide to you because
that's awful okay so ecosystems so this
is where we're gonna look at these
different products in terms of differ
not products these these different
ecosystems in terms of metrics that I
thought were relevant so first off we've
got the maturity of the project so this
one's pretty straightforward apache
spark has been around I think I would
say yeah so spark is about nine and a
half so it's been around for a while I
think dass was approaching its fifth
birthday Rapids I thought was a couple
years old at Keith's today told me it
was a little over a year so somewhere in
the one to two years so the syntax here
like yeah cool okay the you know yellow
warning sign is like you should you know
dig into this a little bit you will see
a red X on the next slide that's like
definitely like warning here so job
scheduling so if you've got jobs that
have to run if you're if you want to
submit jobs to production how do those
work spark has the you know yarn for for
all of its flaws and for all of the
people that hate yarn it still does a
pretty darn good job of getting things
done in a constraint system so you know
if you're on if you've got an on-prem
cluster and you've got limited compute
capacity there right like you're going
to have more people trying to use it
then you have capacity for and yarn does
it quite it yarn does a good job there
Rapids I think this after some
conversations this shouldn't be a red X
because Rapids in many ways will fall
back on whatever tasks can do so the
desk ecosystem will be dependent on its
back-end so if you run task on yarn then
it's the same story of SPARC if you run
tasks on kubernetes and again please you
know come up to me afterwards and tell
me that I'm an idiot because you know
there's this obvious thing that I should
be aware of but from my understanding
kubernetes doesn't have the same type of
kind of queueing mechanisms that yarn
does and you've got the different HPC
backends so slurm at PBS that I am
completely unfamiliar with but they're
there as well so also to keep in mind
the difference between on Prem o'clock
right so if you're on the cloud then
none of this really matters right the
metric is how much you're gonna spend
not like how much you've already got in
place so the notion of kind of queuing
in the cloud is a far less relevant
because you know you just spin up your
elastic coo-coo communities cluster and
you know you don't have a queue but it
might cost a lot so you've got workflow
scheduling right so SPARC you've got
Izzy and Azkaban
I think Azkaban was out of LinkedIn is
that right
maybe anyways
with Rapids and - you've got tools like
airflo and Luigi I think so
show of hands who knows what airflow is
okay cool
Luigi prefect dot IO much less okay so
prefect IO is a company in the space
that will sell you so they have a
product that's air flow plus desk it's
you know and and an interesting option
and and does help kind of my narrative
here around like growing growing this
ecosystem is going to require more
companies in this space that are trying
to support these products that are
seeing the enterprise problems that are
building tools in the open-source space
that will help drive more adoption so I
mean realistically there's good options
on both sides here so with scalability
single node versus to serve a date right
with spark so does anybody here actually
use spark and local mode okay I really
want to talk to you about why not not
only because I think you're like you're
doing anything wrong I'm just curious
because I don't run across people that
frequently that you spark in local mode
so you know maybe that was a bit you
know unnecessarily harsh technically yes
but you know I have no problem being
wrong about any of this so with Rapids
you've got single node performance
that's amazing because you're you're on
you know on the GPU and we've all heard
how GPU makes everything a lot faster
and desk has a great single node story
it's very easy to use it gives you the
api's that you're used to distributed
mode spark versus task that's you know
it's a fairly straightforward story and
Rapids distributed the only reason
that's kind of like like yes ish is
because I don't think that they've got
the full kind of stable of distributed
algorithms that things like desk and
sparked it yet but again I could also be
very wrong about that also I don't know
how common distributed GPU clusters are
yet
so it's not to say that like you know
you can't build one and it's it's not to
say that a video won't happily sell you
one but I just don't know kind of in
terms of finding people that you could
pay to to manage it I think that would
all also be hard all right so algorithm
was right we've got kind of graph
algorithms machine learning and deep
learning again there are good choices
for everything here the only reason why
the machine learning side with spark
here is yellow I don't know how many
people would voluntarily pick ml lib
over scikit-learn I think that my my
kind of you know completely unscientific
poll of people that I've talked to in
the space would much prefer the
scikit-learn API and kind of the rich
ecosystem of algorithms that
scikit-learn will provide over ml Lib
and spork does have XG boost ray but you
also have extra boost available and
asked and I think there's a CUDA
accelerated version of that as well
admittedly I don't know the deep
learning story on spark so you know if
there is a very good very compelling
deep deep learning story there great you
know come come come talk to me again
tell me why I'm and and idiot up here
I'm totally fine with that yeah you know
data visualization this is where like
this is really the spot that I think
spark is missing a big chunk of the
ecosystem I mean I don't again I don't
think that there's a rich ecosystem like
there is in the Python world for
visualizing with spark I mean you know
maybe data bricks has a product that
would be fantastic for this I I just
don't know I I haven't encountered
anybody who does work in spark and then
knows how to visualize their 100 million
or billion row data frame I I personally
know how to do that and Rapids and desk
you you can use data shader and tasks to
you know spin this up and it works great
you can build an an interactive
dashboard that can serve 100 million
rows of data and you know it can
downsample it
time with you know you can zoom in and
zoom out and change filters and all that
it's quite nice in terms of a data frame
API right they've all got this the
biggest hole in the basque ecosystem
right now is the lack of sequel right
there's no sequel compiler in task and
Rapids has there's a product in the
rapid pace called blazing sequel that
gives you this type of an interface so
why do we care about sequel right I mean
it's what 2019 so according to sack
overflow professional developers still
use sequel far more than they would use
Python I also like to take a little jab
at our in Scala here but that's fine
that's fine but but seriously so sequel
is where you know the kind of people
that we will label is less technical
right the business analysts the
marketing scientists but those are the
people that actually know how the
business is run they are incredibly
valuable without those people like your
[ __ ] you're gonna have a much less a
much less effective business and
generally speaking they're all or many
of them are quite comfortable in sequel
so things like spark C cool things like
blazing sequel give your marketing
science team your business analysts
access to your you know petabytes of
data that are locked away I think that's
a big gap in the desk ecosystem
currently regarding data access right
with spark you know you've got access to
HDFS that's three hives flat files etc
pythons got a much richer data data
access story you can access everything
that you can with spark
you know it's probably not as performant
but it doesn't have to be yeah
so streaming wise again this is not
necessarily so much is like which of
these streaming libraries is better it's
more just that they're all there this is
a this is a comparison of ecosystem
functionality more so than it is like a
bake-off between like oh you know - plus
streams is so much better than spark
streaming or that's not what this is
like the capability is there and also
this is you know again I have not spent
enough time in the the streaming world
so this is a real dense slide but this
is effectively a summary of everything
that I just said and I will show I will
have this slide up at the very end for
questions as well so this is not the
last time that you have an opportunity
to take a picture of the slide but you
know the the important takeaway here is
the trend right for the most part they
all have functionality across this this
slice of the ecosystem right there's not
one perfect tool here I mean you could
almost certainly use any of these
independently in terms of their
technical feasibility right I mean in
very specific circumstances maybe you
want more than one of them in the long
term again the biggest holes here are
the the spark ecosystem I think is
lacking a little in the kind of machine
learning deep learning visualization
space compared to the Python space and
of course you know the big red X on task
is a proper sequel engine alright so
time check we're at 18 minutes okay cool
so you know real quick let's start
talking about some of the architecture
some of the infrastructure like the ways
that you would actually start to stand
up some of these things will grow in
complexity we're gonna start with Rapids
right this is a very easy to understand
slide you go by a server from Nvidia and
you can use Rapids it's very easy you
know you've got the Python interfaces to
your your data you certainly can do
shared infrastructure and have multiple
users on a single GPU this is this is
not in any way saying like this is the
perfect art
texture I don't work at Nvidia I have no
idea this is the perfect way to get this
this up and running but in terms of like
ease of use you know in terms of
minimizing the infrastructure costs here
you probably just want to give data
scientists their own server just for
starts then you know people can work by
themselves and get off to the races a
really good way to run desk right now is
desk on kubernetes it's very simple
we've an anaconda this year has been
working on a project called bass gateway
happy to talk more about that later or
if there's time at the end I can
certainly come back to it but basically
you know the idea here is that if you
have kubernetes already or if you want
to run on the cloud you can spin up desk
gateway you Hjelm install it you you can
help install it into an auto scaling
kubernetes cluster it works with
whatever auth you you you have in place
already users will connect to desk
gateway
- game it will spin up a task cluster on
kubernetes desk and we will proxy the
scheduler back to the user end of a
proxy the desk dashboard as well so you
can have everything behind a community
zone and then still you would run the
desk client locally to wherever these
users are and you've got full access to
whatever data you have and also worth
mentioning is that and the Rapids
project can also or the Rapids eat the
ecosystem will also work well it will
work the same way
eventually we need to add support and -
gateway to run desk cuda workers but the
infrastructure would theoretically be
the same air spark own yarn is a much
harder diagram to actually like put up
on a screen there's a lot there
but in terms of getting you know being
useful and getting work done right you
can either SSH into an edge node and run
spark shell or PI spark or install you
know Jupiter notebook and port forward
that you know I know that you three
there in the second row that I worked
with it
point have all done this so you can use
something called Libby which is a server
that you run on the edge noted it
exposes interactive spark over HTTP you
can use a project in the Jupiter
ecosystem called spark magic to connect
to Livi and run interactive spark from
wherever right you've got the sequel
interface with hive and spark sequel
you've got scripting with Pig you know
Hadoop yarn spark okay so so kind of
with that out of the way how do we start
getting PI data how do we start getting
desk and Rapids into the enterprise like
how do we penetrate that space and you
know get it to the level of prominence
that spark has have I happened to find
this really good quote from Shane when I
was doing a bit of research for this
talk and I really like it because it's
basically the same point that I'm trying
to make but it's not from me you know so
clearly at least one other person has
has the the same thought here so I will
read it because it's interesting it's
hard to get organizational buy-in to
adopt an open-source technology without
vendors support and enterprise SLA s so
how many people in this room have fought
the same battle one to you know a
handful probably 10 20 and I talking to
a customer about four months ago they
said this to me I didn't really know
what to say because I was taken aback
right like they're not all in on tasks
because what if anaconda isn't around in
a few years and I was like but it's but
there's more to it than anaconda right
like there's Nvidia's contributing there
are folks well those those are the two
big ones and kuansad as well you know
and and and there's you know a horde of
kind of smaller in individual
contributors but like it definitely
plays to the same point like who were
they supposed to call for help who are
they're supposed to pay for
implementation services like how is this
supposed to work at the enterprise scale
so you know I thought it was relevant
enough here so again as promised a a
reminder of my thesis here these are the
things that enterprises are going to
care about these are the things that
enterprises do care about looking around
for phones up all right I got two all
right so right we're not missing
features all right this is this this
isn't a lack of features in bask right
think about Jupiter hub right I mean
it's not like Jupiter hub isn't I mean
super Drive is everywhere but it but
it's not it's not seeing more adoption
because it lacks features right it's
what we need to see Jupiter hub you know
dominate the landscape our consultancies
around it our people that are solving
these enterprise problems around these
these open source projects so here's
another really fun controversial slide
that you know I'm sure I'll get a lot of
flack for I'm totally fine with that you
know the the whole point here is to
spark a conversation right for all of
these right spark is green across the
bowl blue across the board right I don't
really even know how you would quantify
the risk of adopting Rapids or adopting
tasks inside of your enterprise at the
structure I I don't know right I mean I
think that there's a real big need in
this space for people that really stand
up and proclaim like you know I'm an
expert in desk like pay me and I will
help you figure out you know how to
adopt ask inside of your enterprise in
terms of institutional support or a desk
has you know at least three companies
behind it right now we've got anaconda
and Quan site and Nvidia in terms of
institutional support for Rapids I think
that's pretty much Nvidia at this point
again you know come tell me that I'm
wrong they're right but in terms of the
risk right if you only have one company
behind this open-source ecosystem that
you're building your business on you
know if they decide that they don't want
to you know build rapids any more than
you know risk right same story with
consulting and implementation services I
don't know of anybody right now that you
could go and
a for support and implementation on in
the rapids ecosystem but again I don't
know that I would expect it either
because right there like one to two
years old Ford asked again I know of
Quon site I don't know of anybody else
again if you are that person and come
and talk to me training wise I know that
you can get training support for desk
and I'm just ignoring spark because you
can get these things from an ocean of
consultancies or Claude area or data
breaks or EMR or you know there's a lot
of ways in which you can get that
training services I'm pretty sure you
could go to Quon side to get training on
Rapids yeah yes okay Thank You Anthony
and then kind of the same thing with a
risk I don't really know how to quantify
the time to value and total cost of
ownership for tools like gasket rapids
uh it's a good quick look at my
presenting news yeah okay all right so
what do we do well for starters you
could build a proper sequel engine a
proper sequel compiler and desk that'll
that'll that'll help you on board more
job titles to the desk ecosystem that
gets you the business analyst the
marketing scientist business
intelligence etc you know the people
again actually know how your your
business works
you can sort a product company in the
space to productize something around
desk or Rapids that'll that'll reach
more enterprises you can start a
consulting company around desk or Rapids
although it's probably a little early
for Rapids that'll help to make it
sticky in these enterprises that want to
use desk but need help so for those of
you in the enterprise right for the
actual practitioners you're like what
can you do with these ecosystems how
should you think about using them and
adopting them so the first question is
do you already have spark right and if
you have spark great like you you you
have a tool that you can use if you want
to use desk - gateway works with spark
right there's there's a number of
projects in the desk ecosystem letters
we designed to work with spark on on
yarn there's desk yarn
there's desk Gateway that you can
install alongside your Hadoop cluster
where a desk Gateway will then talk to
yarn and provision yarn containers and
run desk desk workers inside of those
yarn containers so you get to use desk
without needing any new adoption of any
new infrastructure and if you don't have
SPARC already then you know you should
probably think long and hard about
adopting it it's a it's a very complex
stack question - do you have kubernetes
if you do great helm installed desk
gateway you'll probably need to work
with your IT teams and your info SEC
teams but at least you don't need to try
and argue that you need new
infrastructure
do you have GPUs again if you do awesome
right you know you can Conda installed
desk or Rapids and just start playing
around with it and figure out if it
solves the use case and in it and if it
does then you've got some more ammo to
go say look we need to invest more in
this it solves these kinds of problems
then the obvious question is do you have
cloud access and if you do great you
know you can use desk on an auto scale
and cute kubernetes cluster you can try
Rapids on some GPU instances very low
risk here but you still are also really
gonna need the need to make the case
about why you should be adopting tasks
why I should be adopting Rapids and it's
not it's not gonna be the the easiest
thing in the world again because you
can't go pay somebody to help you make
that argument right there's there's no
support or I mean there's open-source
support but you can't the enterprise
need for support isn't there uh okay
cool so in summary right we've got I
mean desk and Rapids are basically at
ecosystem feature parity with SPARC the
reasons why desk and Rapids and spark or
desking rapids are not seeing the same
adoption as spark as is not due to
features you know we need companies in
this space and you can also start using
these tools so came in a lot under what
I thought I was going to so thank you
for listening
[Applause]
nice box
alright so unfortunately I find four
questions in this very controversial
topic so here we go yeah I thought it
was a great talk
it's just a question how much do you
think the adoption of spark was driven
by offerings by the major cloud
providers I mean Amazon picked it up in
like 2015 and that's like what four
years after after it was released by
Berkeley would that mean that like desk
and Rapids would be at least like four
years out before you would see major
cloud adoption well I mean so that's a
that's a good question I I don't have a
good answer for you I mean I like I
think that Basques is I think that desk
is kind of approaching that spa where we
can start to expect to see oh
good Anthony great where we can start to
see some some cloud companies start some
like bask as a service tech companies I
in fact Hugo has one hugo's you know
goal here is to be data bricks for desk
as I will say but you know you should
talk to him because it's okay well there
you go yeah so database for desk right
here so I would expect these to start to
to show up for tasks certainly and like
honestly I ate I think the cloud
landscape was 2015 is very different
from the cloud landscape of 2019 so
we'll see all right what you got Anthony
all right
hi Eric so it occurs to me that you're
overloading the term ecosystem here to
mean both corporate ecosystem and and
community ecosystem and does it seem it
seems like those the point of this talk
is to try to resolve some of those
discrepancies and maybe help bring an
open-source ecosystem into kind of just
to be able to serve the needs of these
corporate ecosystems are there resources
available that help like inform and
educate us all about how that happens
and and and help resolve those two two
ecosystems
that's a very good question which I
suspected look at it I don't know I mean
it like it takes like it takes you know
people that are kind of that are
bridging that that gap that are both
involved in open source but are also in
the enterprise and kind of trying to
drive these kinds of problems and like
and I solve these kinds of problems you
know that sounds like a great
opportunity to write some intersting
blog posts but in terms of like you know
broader resources and tools I you know
open to ideas
Thanks oh we have a time for one more
question all right cool
well thanks everybody all right thank
you
[Applause]